uh i've been reading some martin gardner
books all sorts of gems in there here's
one i haven't practiced very much
it just needs a die i want you to pick a
number on the die don't tell me what it
is
so i can't actually see anything at all
yep which means that you
can feel free to sort of i know show the
the video watches
let's go for that number a whole number
right you haven't got a picked pie or
something
no it's a it's an integer okay and it's
on a die good
you should be able to see three numbers
on the die yes i can
can you see your number no
interesting
can you see your number now yes
that's interesting
can you see your number now yes
is it the one on top i think so yep you
got it
[Laughter]
well i'm excited
[Laughter]
how did you do that again can you can
you teach it so people can do it to
their parents i can't do it
do you have any idea because i've never
tried this trick on anyone before and
first of all with all magic tricks
there's a trick right but when you know
the trick
thing's lame i've just done a lame thing
is it at all interesting
that i could know with blindfolded what
your number was
yeah okay can we try it one more time
yeah and i think you might
start to spot what's going on like all
magic tricks you repeat it and you're
like wait a second so
all right so you you decide a number
again let's go
for uh let's go for that number i'm
trying to point a corner towards you so
it's interesting on a d6 you can only
ever see three numbers can you see
your number now no interesting
so let's try the question again there
can you see your number now
yes that's interesting what about
what about now no that's very intriguing
why would you choose that number
yes
why would you choose a one i mean that's
what lost you in that game
all right when i first saw this i was
like ah it's like what they call a
binary search
a binary search is where you're hunting
for something that you don't know and
you
try and eliminate half the possibilities
in one go and that's kind of the key to
this i'm asking three questions
and that should be enough information
it's just that doing it with a blindfold
somehow makes it feel
surprising i'm still surprised that i
get it right
audrey i know you're impressed too
audrey
audrey out do you want to roll a die
out no okay out how do we
how do we do how do you do it so a
binary search get rid of half the
options with each question
and a moment's thought i hope reveals
that
i've only got six options so first of
all i could ask six questions
the trick would be a bit rubbish is it
one no is it two
i guarantee you i think i did those in
three questions
and if you have something three times
actually you've reduced from eight to
one so
three halvings should be plenty of
questions to get this so
that's the that's the base principle
like i'm just asking enough questions so
i think i can talk you through
this the first thing is is one of the
six numbers i ask a question which is
can you see your number and if you say
yes what do i know narrowed up to three
yeah and i'm blindfolded but i can still
feel there's three faces there there and
there that i know you can see if you say
yes i know it's those three if you say
no
i know it's one of those three so i've
halved it and then the next question is
if i ask you then
let's say you say no on that and i spin
it round if i then ask you
can you see your number it's a stupid
question right because i know you can
so i need to hide one of these and all i
did was spin that forward
and now i know that two of them are ones
that
might be your number and if i say can
you see your number and you say no
i knew that these two were possibles and
the one on the bottom
is also possible and you can't see it so
the one on the bottom
is your number but if you said yes then
it's one of these two so i just need to
hide one of those two
and now that one's the only possible one
that you can see
or it's the one that you can't see so if
you say no it's that one
if you say yes there's that one let's
use the number one again okay so you've
chosen one but i don't know that i'm
blindfolded i can't see anything but i
know that if i spin the die
so that you can see three then i ask a
question yes or no can you see your
number
and in this case you would say yes so i
know it's one of these three
if you'd said no i would have known as
one of those three in this case it's not
so i've already got
half the solutions out of the way i now
want to ask again
if i didn't move it i wouldn't be
getting any new information so i'm going
to hide one of these three gonna hide
that one so now
i know that these two faces are
possibles and the one on the bottom
so can you see your number yes so i know
even though i'm blindfolded that it's
one of these two so let's hide one of
them
can you see your number no it's the one
i just hit which is on the bottom
that's it and because of this halving
business
i'm guaranteed to get down to only one
left
in at most three turns in fact it might
go even quicker
let's do it now if the one wasn't
visible
in the first go okay and i'm also going
to rig it slightly to show how it could
go even quicker but
can you see your number no so under the
cover of my hands if
i'm blindfolded i'd spin this all the
way around and that's my mental check
right it's one of those three numbers
and i would hide one of them now i don't
know which one to hide but i've just got
a sort of consistent way of rolling it
so i'm convinced i know where it is
and now i say can you see your number no
and i know it must be the one i've just
hidden then so which point i just clean
up
walk away in two turns and that's
nicer although as a performer for me i'm
like
it just feels really lame i just like
just asked a couple of questions but i
still think the effect is quite nice and
it's a nice demonstration of
searching efficiently and it also means
that if eight is what
doubling three times gives you so
halving three times gets you back to one
i've got more than enough information i
should be able to do this on a d8
can you do it with the d8 mathematics
says i can
practice means i'm a bit nervous but we
can have a try this is an octahedron and
it does have eight
sides but i can see four at a time now
yeah that's true so we've got
and i think if i aim a corner towards
you you can only see those four can you
see those four
yeah okay the most difficult thing with
me in my blindfolding is like orienting
the dice so you can actually see the
fork because if i put it like that i
don't know what you can see
would you want to do this one
unblindfolded no we'll do it blindfolded
all right
all right should i choose a number
choose a number okay don't tell me
whatever you do all right
let's go for that number so you and the
camera can see
four numbers yep uh can you see your
number no
you can't see your number so i'm kind of
hiding what i'm doing you might want to
speculate about what i'm doing
uh let's go with
can you see your number uh no i can't
you can't see your number
this is the bit that i'm just super
feeling my way about
can you see
oh dear can you see your number
now uh
no interesting
your number is on top on top there do
you want the good news or the bad news i
want both
you got it yes
but i knew i was going to get it all
along because i'm supremely confident in
mathematics
and my tactile blind handling of a d8
let's do the five again so you go for
five so can you see your number
yes but all i know is it's one of these
four my next job is to harp the amount
of information so i need to hide two of
these faces so i did that
in this case by just rolling over like
that i know that two of the ones you
could see are now missing but two of
them
are visible so can you see your number
yes so as i know it's one of these two
i'm kind of feeling with my first two
fingers each time thinking it's one of
those two if you said no
i knew it'd be one of those two that i
first showed you but i've got to keep
track of where they are with my
blindfold
but since he said yes i know it's one of
these two so i just got to hide one of
those two
so let's just roll it onto there so i
know that
one of them is on the bottom that helps
me know where it is and one of them is
visible and i know it's the front one i
say can you see your number and you say
no in which case i know it's the one i
just hid so i flip it over
and flourish or something and sort of
start sweating about whether i've
actually got it nice
but it's it's a nice example of like
searching efficiently if you've got
a lot of things trying to halve it each
time is one of the most efficient and
that's partly why
binary as a number system is like used
in computers because it's kind of an
efficient way of thinking about breaking
up numbers that's just a nice
demonstration of
a binary search the fact that you can do
it on a d6 martin gardner talked about
doing on a d6 and i was like
that means it must be possible on a d8
can you do a higher d now there's
some options right there's a d10 that
could be done in
four questions uh d12
the dodecahedron icosahedron that could
be done in four and that could be done
in five but it's hard i mean i'm finding
the octahedron hard enough
so i need a lot more practice but it
could be done and the thing is i start
to doubt whether the impressiveness like
four questions
feels like quite a lot the fact that the
d6
sometimes works out in two is what gives
that little kicker like boom boom
got it brush up on your dice mathematics
as part of this casino probability
course
on brilliant today's episode sponsor now
it doesn't matter if you get things
right
or occasionally wrong you're always
learning with brilliance fantastic
quizzes and
puzzles and their deep dive courses
i do really enjoy doing these
interactive gets my brain turning
yeah premium subscribers get access to
everything on brilliant but there's also
plenty of stuff to see
for free so why not go check them out
see what you make of it
if you do want to become a premium
subscriber number five viewers are going
to get 20
off by going to brilliant.org
number five that's brilliant.org
number five they're on the screen and if
you're already a member why not consider
gifting one of those premium
subscriptions to
the student or the lifelong learner in
your life
[Music]
what does that mean well of course we
know what it means in practice we mean
if we throw it
you know it should land on each of the
30 faces 30th of the time but
let me talk about that for a second when
i was a graduate student
we had a guy who was a retired executive
who wanted to test the laws of chance
and say well this means more often than
that that's the end of the story so the
totem pole continues like this
this one beats this one and this one
beat this one
so i think this is almost for the simple
game you're not playing against someone
else
aim for 20 is a good piece of advice